all right so this movie is called Jack
Reacher never go back so why isn't the
catchphrase once you go Jack you never
go back like if you're gonna have a
boring ass movie at least have a fun ass
catchphrase [ __ ]
[Music]
once you go Jack you never go back
whatever I'm gonna call it that so Jack
Reacher never go back as a sequel to the
original Jack Reacher in which case we
get to see Tom Cruise phoning it in for
about two hours Jack Reacher's phone
friend whom he's never met in his entire
life is ultimately being held for a
crime she didn't commit and he's trying
to prove her innocence and then he gets
arrested for a crime he didn't commit
oh and this girl who may or may not be
his daughter sprinkled in there too but
seriously they're trying to prove a
thing here and they're trying to dig up
information here the movie is so choppy
as it does it once in a while they'll
run across the person you're like hoses
why are we here movies not concise man
it doesn't focus up this point and that
it's kind of like die hard five who's
the bad guy did you people why are they
doing it because and there is no
chemistry in this movie at all sir I got
to think either the actors just
naturally don't like each other
naturally don't work well together they
just naturally don't want to be there
probably the last one of the three
people all right generally this is how
it breaks down he likes her he doesn't
like her she likes her she doesn't like
him she likes her she doesn't like him
seriously though that girl who may or
may not be his daughter that is tagging
along in this whole adventure I just her
character annoyed me frustrated me to no
end I would have thrown her off a
building I want but when they're all in
Mardi Gras - but like you used the
credit card when I told you they can
track that [ __ ] you know what huh
oh come on don't give me that look she
she's a credit card she's literally more
trouble than she's worth
we're safe now she's angsty she's
annoying she's unlikable and she's a
liability she's a problem for these
people whether she's using a phone she
shouldn't be using or a credit card she
shouldn't be using she never learns and
she always gets them into trouble and
she just pisses me off when you have a
character you're supposed to root for
and maybe root for a connection her and
Jack Reacher have or may or may not have
but it's so hard because she's just
unlikable and I don't blame the actress
at all I mean she's a young actress I
want to see her get more work I don't
think this is a good showcase for her I
know not to blame her because everyone
else is phoning it in to Tom Cruise is
phoning in and I can't blame that girl
when the directing or writing at that
point holy [ __ ] guys in the end jack
reacher never go back was worse than the
first Jack Reacher movie whatever you
thought about Jack Reacher movie love it
or hate it
this is worse no matter what it's boring
I was yawning the movie feels like it's
four hours long it's not concise it's
not focused you barely know what the
point of all this [ __ ] is the characters
have no chemistry whatsoever and in the
end the only saving grace is when Jack
Reacher is actually kicking some ass
he's probably on autopilot at this point
he's like oh I get to be you know a 50
year old who kicks ass like a 20 year
old let's do it that's always neat to
see but in the end you are not gonna
remember this movie in t-minus 10
minutes yeah or they forgot all right
guys so Jack Reacher never go back have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's the most annoying side
character like tag-along character in a
movie ever for you not counting Jar Jar
Binks that [ __ ] is too easy
whoever it is whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]